at the center of it all Purdue big man
Zach Edie and while the heartbreaking
finish is undoubtedly adding fuel to his
competitive fire as we found out before
the tournament began it's one that was
lit long ago
[Music]
at 7-4 305 pounds Zach Edie is an
immovable Force
[Applause]
his regular season dominance helping
earn the junior big man at Purdue Big
Ten Player of the Year honors and
favored status for National player of
the year but what's beneficial on the
court is a bit different off it
it's tough being tall
what is the toughest thing about being
always stuck in under everyone you know
you'll wake up kind of early morning
you'll have that fog and just hit your
head in a doorway and just ruins your
whole day size and sports have always
been a part of Edie's life Zachary go
and growing up in Toronto Canada you
betcha one of his first athletic
passions was hockey I started playing
from a young age Oh I thought I was
young I started like skating at like
when I was six years old that's old in
Canada yeah it's considered a little
older for people in Canada baseball was
his other love a pitcher six feet tall
by age 11 and growing from there I
wanted to play pro sports I want to be
the tallest pitcher ever put Randy
Johnson to shame yeah were you always
the biggest kid on the team
yeah since elementary school I've been
the biggest person on the team including
the coaches now
you said hockey in baseball but no
basketball why not I had no like ill
feeling towards the sport just people
always try to get me to play it so I
like didn't want to play it at all I was
like my thing typical kid if you're
telling me to do it exactly I don't want
to do it but when injury and
Circumstance put baseball Out Of Reach a
seven-foot Edie changed his Outlook
giving basketball a shot Midway through
his sophomore year of high school and
when I first started playing in 10th
Grade I remember I went to practice
looking back on it it wasn't a fun
practice to be at everyone was doing
like skills work I was just working on
trying to like go my right foot left
foot into a right foot right hand Leia
like just like the super super
fundamentals but I think it was just
kind of a challenge of like learning
something new with his competitive fire
lit 80 turned to the IMG Academy in
Florida where he'd get two years of
intensive basketball training while
finishing High School he'd graduate with
a scholarship to play D1 ball for the
Purdue Boilermakers well we thought he'd
be good we just didn't know Winnie was
going to be good yeah Purdue head coach
Matt Painter knew Edie's limited time in
the game meant he'd have work to do he
looked really good in workouts then the
game started and it wasn't that he was
bad it was kind of like he was
non-existent he was kind of finding
himself and kind of figuring things out
and then after about six or seven games
a lot of it just stopped what do you
think changed I just think watching tape
and doing a lot of drill work with our
coaches he really worked you know hard
on those things in in a quick study you
know he got better is there an advantage
to him being a kid that wasn't learning
these things age five sure just because
you don't have those bad habits and he's
a sponge Edie gives the Boilermakers
coaching staff proper credit for their
role in his rapid development and
they're not the only ones who've made a
difference what have you loved about
being here at Mackie for games oh the
environment is insane Julia Edie is
Zach's mom I think until he really
found high level Sport and then
particularly basketball
he hasn't been able to just release that
kind of inner Zach you know we used to
joke and say like release the Zach and I
think he's getting to do that what has
that been like to see his growth
absolutely incredible he's really
included Me In the Journey you know like
oh my God I'm gonna cry
um you know he
it's just amazing I've been able to be
part of it with him as he goes along he
you know leans into me and then leans
out when he kind of needs to I'm
watching him grow
something made a bit easier thanks to
proximity starting when Zach was a
freshman Julia made the in-season move
from Toronto to West Lafayette for
relocation not only welcomed by her son
but also made possible when he got his
scholarship she retired something Zach
had wanted to do for her since he was a
kid he talked about when he was younger
wanted to play baseball and get a
scholarship so you could retire yeah and
he did that for you now not with
baseball but with basketball yeah it's
crazy because when he first I mean it
was maybe he was 12 and he said you know
he wanted to go to the states for school
and I said you know what if I go to
States I can get a scholarship like you
had this whole plan I said to him that's
not your job you know I'm fine I've got
a good job I can do it and then when he
actually was doing it I thought this is
crazy and I'd always said to him I won't
miss a minute like if that happens I'm
not going to miss a minute and yeah
I'm so glad I mean I'm just so grateful
and she's not the only one what has that
meant to have her here with you a little
bit it's great obviously to see a
familiar face in the crowd and she's at
every home game at a lot of the away
games she has like team over and we'll
she'll just cook that meal and then
we'll just kind of have a good time over
there what's been the best part of
watching him this year well
it's not just this year it's just
watching him grow as a person and
becoming kind of the person that I think
he wants to be sometimes I have to pause
with him you know I remember even the
first year when he was down here oh and
I said to him okay just do something for
me I just want you to pause for a second
and look around and say
oh my gosh like you're in a D1 school
your March Madness March Madness you're
with Purdue like this is crazy and I
remember him kind of pausing for a
second or looking at me and you know
saying
whoa A Mother's words of wisdom that
have certainly sunken in if the goal
when you were younger was to be a pro
baseball player
the goal now the NBA for sure do you
allow yourself to think about that I try
not to try to just like kind of stay in
this moment enjoy the moment I want to
look at my future and then kind of Miss
what's happening right now I think
what's happening right now it's one of
the best times of my life
I love my teammates it's just been an
unbelievable ride this year and I don't
want to miss out on it it's because I'm
thinking about something that might
happen in the future
and with that unexpected exit from the
tournament now it's that forced time to
think about the future a couple things
Zach's mom told me that his Love of the
Game is something she's really embraced
because she told him it's not always
going to be good like what they're
experiencing right now and he will
contemplate the future he said that he
loves this team he'd love to stay with
them but he also knows he has to think
about the financial future so now he has
time to make that decision it's pretty
amazing that he was six feet tall by age
11. yeah and still didn't play
basketball until he was 15 or 16. I just
didn't want to I loved it